cleaning. I'm cleaning my personal care items also include no hair. So I think the question is
as I clean up my personal care items, should I also be looking at my hair coloring?
Yes. So chemicals, you women are more
assaulted by cancer-causing chemicals than men are because women are going to be more
have more of a tendency to use lotions and creams and certainly cosmetics. And there's some of the
most cancer-causing things. There's an interview somewhere on our blog post. I'm being interviewed.
I can't remember the guy's name, I'm so sorry, but a gentleman over in Europe, I think he was in
he's in France and he's a specialist in environmental toxins and especially was it pertains to
personal care items. And he told me that there's 1300 different chemicals that are banned in the
European Union that are permitted in the United States that are in our personal care item products.
There are all carcinogens, 1300 different carcinogens that they can make personal care products
without, and they do, and they sell them in Europe without it, but they, if they make it
with it, I don't know, it may make it more creamy or colorful or whatever, but it's toxic
and it's a carcinogenic and yet we are being exposed to it. So yes, women especially have to
go through their personal care products because when I say men don't have as many personal care products,
but and then you talk about cleaning up your home like your cleaning products,
your things that you wash your clothes and things that you wash your dishes and things that you
use for dish washing detergent, things that you, you know, clean the floor with.
You're exposed, those things, you're exposed to those toxins, they have to, you remember anything that
you absorb any which way but lose into your system. If you don't detoxify it, it becomes a
car to you and it settles in cells and it can be a cancer-causing thing and worse, and other things too.
So crosses the blood-brain barrier, it causes inflammation in the brain, it causes early dementia,
all these different things. So the more you can clean up the environment, the better you can do.